can you hear that what is that noise
must mean it's the cheeky scientist a
Christmas special
yeah and dressed like an elf anyway
sense it's almost Christmas I thought I
tell you why I envy buddy the elf but is
it healthy so I suspect if you're
actually watching this video you've
probably seen the film elf and if you
haven't stopped the video right now and
go watch the film say awesome but anyway
elf is a great film no doubt about it
but buddy the main character in the film
and the only ously artistically gifted I
mean he'd read the Mona Lisa on an
etch-a-sketch but he also seems to be
able to depend on a minimal amount of
sleep when he was asked how did you
sleep last night buddy he replied grades
I got a full 40 minutes
what no wonder I'm envious of buddy he
gets to spend only 2.8 percent for stay
sleeping whilst we spend about 1/3 of a
day sleeping think about the amount of
trashy videos I could make in that time
but you know what's the stop me sleeping
40 minutes each day why do we actually
need more time to sleep than that why do
we even sleep from the first place so
let's start with the basics
what actually is sleep so sleep isn't
the absence of wakefulness it's an
active state is regulated and it's
metabolically distinct and it's
essential for our health and well-being
it is also evolutionarily conserved in
the majority of organisms ranging from
once through to humans and so sleep can
be split up into four different stages
we have non REM sleep and REM sleep with
REM standing for rapid eye movement so
REM sleep is meant to occur normally
during the second half of the night and
that's is said to be when you have your
dreams
whereas non REM sleep can be split up
further into three different stages
which are light intermediates and deep
sleep
and so REM and non-rem occurs throughout
and it seems to oscillate between the
two different stages of sleep and the
extent and duration of these different
phases fluctuates between different
people and within an individual as well
so weak fullness and sleep are both
highly regulated such that they don't
occur at the same time so to actually
initiate sleep it requires the
suppression of the activity in the
arousal systems that keep you awake and
what is known as that this inhibition of
wakefulness is achieved by neurons in
the ventral lateral preoptic area and
these neurons remain active throughout
the sleep periods so what actually
triggers the activation of these neurons
well probably a whole bunch of different
molecules but one likely candidate is
adenosine since there are many adenosine
receptors on these neurons and then
Essene accumulates throughout the day
and it should also not be surprising
therefore that sleeper score so it's
occasionally regulated and so in the
evening you see an increase in melatonin
secretion which is often referred to as
the sleep hormone so why sleep so
important then why is this essential for
health well there is an entire book
about why we sleep written by Matt
Walker which even Bill Gates recommends
that you read actually it's one of his
Christmas recommendations I have
actually read it myself but they have
watched Matt Walker give several talks
online one of which was a recent TED
talk that he gave which I'll link up
there for you but I will share with you
now a few key points one being that
short sleep predicts all cause mortality
quite the hard-hitting statement so
sorry buddy
but this wasn't the only terrifying
statistics that Matt talks about in the
title he also talks about the
consequences of the daylight saving time
changes so this is when the clocks go
forward in spring and back an hour in
autumn so what was seen in a US study
was that in spring when the clocks go
forwards and you lose an hour sleep
there was an increase in around 20% of
heart attacks the next day but the
reverse was seen in autumn so when
people gained an extra hour there was
around a 20% decrease in the rates of
people having heart attacks the next day
pretty shocking and
find sophistic and it's also the reasons
why people are trying to prevent
daylight saving time changes and just to
keep it consistent throughout the year
and just another shocking statistic that
I'll share with you is that in
sleep-deprived individuals so this is
after one night with only four hours
sleep they saw a reduction in the
natural killer cells activity so these
are your immune system response cells
and the decrease was 70% thousand
seventeen that's seventy so even from
these few statistics we can evidently
see how important sleep is but the scary
thing is that when we age there
generally seems to be a decline in sleep
in particular there is less slow-wave
sleep in the end REM stage I was going
to further explain that that's the non
REM stage but it is the non REM stage
anywho this decline is accelerated in
patients with Alzheimer's disease
compared to age match controls so our
summer Ceci's is the most common
neurodegenerative disease and I have a
video about that which you can click on
up there and so as I was saying sleep
disturbance it's one of the earliest
observable symptoms of patients with
Alzheimer's disease and as I'll go on to
explain there now seems to be a
bi-directional link between having poor
sleep and out-science disease but
outside the C's and poor sleep and this
creates a vicious cycle whereby poor
sleep increases the likelihood of
Alzheimer's disease progression that's
also the symptoms of people without
signs disease triggers poor sleep and so
it's just perpetual cycle and so the
evidence for this is currently limiting
in humans and elves but there's been
many studies that have been performed in
rodents that does support this
bi-directional link but just before I
tell you about that the important facts
to know is that outside mr. C's is
characterized by the presence of amyloid
beta plaques and intracellular
neurofibrillary tangles so one
experiment performs and rodents was to
experimentally increase the levels of
amyloid beta and what they saw was they
saw an increase in the fragmentation of
the non REM sleep
other experiments have looked at the
converse whereby they disrupted an REM
sleep and increased the wait time and
escalation of amyloid-beta plaque
formation but why is this happening what
is the cause of this bi-directional link
now the cause for this is not completely
known
but one potential system that could be
involved is the glymphatic system now I
would suspect that not many people have
heard of the glymphatic system before
and I haven't really known about it
until I looked into this research and so
what the glymphatic system is is the
microscopic waist clearance system of
the central nervous system which
includes the brain and the spinal cord
and like how we like to keep our houses
claim the brain and spinal cord should
also be clear and free of toxic and
waste products that build up over time
including amyloid beta plaques but the
rate of this clearance of the glymphatic
system appears to be much greater during
sleep than wakefulness in particular the
majority seems to occur during non-rem
sleep because this is at a stage where
the glial cells which are the non
neurons of the brain they shrink and
this enables a greater flux or fluid to
flow through and clear out all of that
toxic junk within the cells and so just
to make things worse so far we kind of
accumulated all of this disease and
disruption to a lack of sleep but what a
lack of sleep also means is that you
increase the time that you're awake
which means more time for metabolic
distress so actually when we talk about
deprivation of sleep it has to include
both the impacts of less sleep and the
impacts that extended wakefulness so we
can now put all of this information
together to summarize our current
understanding of the link between sleep
and Alzheimer's disease so we'll place
amyloid beta plaques in the center since
it is one of the characteristics of out
sinus disease and from that study in the
rodents they saw that's a low beta
increase disrupts the non REM phase of
sleep and so we also know that the non
REM phase asleep is where you have an
increase in the glymphatic clearance and
because it's a sleep phase lot of wake
phase there's less oxidative stress and
let's build up of metabolic byproducts
so by inhibiting this with amyloid beta
you disrupt
and REM sleep and and REM sleep is
needed to prevent the build-up of
amyloid plaques so you get inhibition of
the inhibition and say because amyloid
beta plaques seems to prevent non REM
sleep it also increases the time spent
awake and so during wakefulness there is
less clearance of the lymphatic system
there is an increase in the production
of oxidative stress and metabolic
byproducts and this all in all
contributes to the increase in the
production of amyloid beta plaques say
this is a positive reinforcement loop so
you know it's not looking very good
really is it but that's not the end of
the story because sleep could be used as
a biomarker now two major goals in out
some of the C's research at the moment
is to try and increase early detection
and also to provide better methods of
treatment of the disease sleep could be
the solution to both of these for
example one method could be to increase
the production of non REM sleep which
could be achieved by using transcranial
direct current stimulation but these are
kind of early days this kind of research
and in terms of early detection you may
be one of the few people already using
apps on your phones and watches actually
track your sleep in the accuracy isn't
great yet but with more people using
them the software will get better and it
could be a really useful way to track
and REM sleep patterns so instead of
envying but ideals
maybe I should be more concerned about
them but then again body is a human
raised by elves whereas we're all humans
raised by humans
maybe that's the missing difference
maybe the elves eat something different
it's all that sugar he knows but the
overlooked thing is that will ferrell
actually had very bad sleep whilst
filming elf cheated all the sugar that
he had so who knows without gays but
anyway for today I'm going to on elf
myself as sleep is biological necessity
say Merry Christmas and hope you have a
good night's sleep and don't stay up
waiting for Santa so yes it would be
very productive to have only 40 minutes
sleep but hopefully this video has told
you why we do need sleep and therefore
why it may not be a healthy choice for
you so as always
have a good Christmas I'm done to
listening